let me ask
for um
for therapy for advice for wisdom in uh
returning to Eric Weinstein and maybe
give some guidance to understanding
his view on um his attempt at Theory of
Everything they call it geometric Unity
that he told me that you may have some
inkling of an under understanding of
if you were to describe this Theory to
aliens that visited Earth
oh
how would you do it or you could try if
it was just me visiting Earth uh how
would you describe your best
understanding of it
he he shared with me some of it when I
was in New York at Colombia like 11
years ago we actually spent a lot of
time where he explained to me and I
found it beautiful
it has a very um original idea at the
core of it where you have this instead
of four-dimensional instead of 10
dimensional he has 14 dimensional space
and I thought it was it was really
original and this is exactly it goes to
the point I made earlier that we need
new ideas
I feel that without some fundamental new
idea we won't be able to get closer to
understanding our universe now I have a
problem with the whole idea of Theory of
Everything You know I don't believe that
one exists nor nor that we should
um
aim to construct one
and I think it's it's really um not to
offend anybody but it's ultimately a
fault of education system of physicists
like in mathematics we do not we're not
brought up we're not educated as
mathematicians with the idea that one
day we will come up with the theory of
everything even though as a joke I said
that language program is mathematical
Theory of Everything
but I mean it's a kind of a
tongue-in-cheek but isn't a little bit
kind of that it's not really because
first of all it doesn't cover all fields
of mathematics and it covers specific
phenomena but isn't it spiritually
striving towards the same platonic form
of the theory of everything like
connecting connecting but connecting
doesn't mean that it covers everything
right so you could connect two things
and then you have a infinitely many
other things which are outside of the
purview of this connection
that's how it is in mathematics I I feel
and I would venture to say that most
mathematicians look at it this way like
there's no idea that somehow I think
it's actually impossible because we're
not talking about such a thing as like
one Universe we're talking about all
possible universes of all possible
dimensions and so on it is just not
feasible to have a unified unify
everything in one equation
now physicists on the other hand have
been brought up educated for decades
with this idea and to me and I I'm not
sure I should say that but I feel like
it's a kind of an ultimate ego trip
so that I have come up with the unified
I have found the entire Theory of
Everything it's me and my name will be
on it I think a lot of physicists get
educated this way especially men take it
seriously yeah and I've seen that happen
and I think it is counterproductive I
think that a lot of people agree that
this debate is kind of I feel like it's
kind of settled I think I hear it less
and less
but I disagree with the whole premise so
you uh it's interesting because because
both are interesting points you made
which is you don't think a Theory of
Everything exists and
you don't think the pursuit of a theory
of everything is good so I think you
spoke to the second thing which is
basically uh that the pursuit of a
theory of everything becomes like a drug
to the human ego that's right so it is a
huge motivating factor I don't deny that
but I feel that it's there are better
ways to motivate people than like that
then this way okay so
um I would say for instance if one
because then it's not a game of Winner
Takes to all in some sense
and In fairness when physicists say
Theory of Everything Grand unified
theory they mean something very specific
which is unifying the standard model and
Einstein's relativity Theory which is
the theory of gravity
so they don't necessarily accordions
might say this worse but they don't
really mean them
I think it's important to realize that
that in my opinion that's not productive
and it's not visible anyway so having
said that there are some theories are
better than others obviously so for
instance Eric's theory has as far as I
understand does have a certain way of
producing some of the elementary
particles that we see and as well as the
force of gravity so it does have that
promise
I feel that from at least from the place
where I had seen it about 10 years ago
it still required a lot of work to get
to the point of actually saying that it
does work because
you know a lot there are a lot of
elements it's a it's a huge Enterprise
to have a theory because you have just
to describe the fields sort of the the
building blocks of the theory it's
already tremendous undertaking and he's
trying to do it for curved spaces and
greater generality which is what makes
it so unique and so beautiful
but then that on top of that there are
this issue of quantization of actually
describing them as Quantum field Theory
and the quantum field Theory even as a
language as a framework is currently
incomplete in my opinion and not only my
opinion it's like everybody's uh it's uh
everybody agrees on that that it's a
it's a
it's a collection of Tricks so it's a
collection of tools it's a toolbox but
it is not a a
consistent rigorous Theory like number
theory in mathematics physicist has
still have still been able to derive
predictions
uh from it by and um confirm them with
to Great accuracy but the underpinnings
that it doesn't have the real grigorous
Foundation from mathematical perspective
so in that sense even if
in that framework a new Theory
could
um lead to an explanation of some some
new explanation of some phenomena it
would still be incomplete in a sense
because it wouldn't be mathematically
rigorous issue what I mean because the
whole framework is not yet on a firm
foundation
so it's not consistent